tooi wrestles his stick away and steps in
here Sai shoots wa on and vas's got that
there is no rebound the NHL will do that to
you especially when you're 19 shot goes wide
rebound off the board ends up with BR and he
fires from close range and a sharp an Cherry
give it a bump Center the qual here's red it's
with a shot and a good save by vanich on Darren
radish this one goes into the corner up to get
it is Hegel he's angled off of the puck in comes
Celli now Celli download to Hegel back there's
a shot sa by vanichic on radish another Drive
scores tipped in front by Nick Paul and that's is
points number 700 for Victor Hond [Music] and it
just comes way off the Pat and all the way off
the end the side boards excuse me out to Victor
Hedman and if Victor keeps it low he's been so
good at that this year here's the initial shot
that was a rocket see and it kicks all the
way out Victor said okay right back to he'll
drop it back to cudra quickly up to point back to
cudra and now they'll set things up again headman
to point in the corner it's Nikita K Dro to St
goes set by vanich he didn't get all of that one
cell across to headman headman in towards the
head rebound there for Paul and it hopped off
his sck back to him and slap shot in front heel
battling for it [Music] [Applause] scar Brandon
angle finds some loose change in front of the net
and makes it two nothing lightning play possible
here gets a it gets a handle on it but see how it
gets away and then he swipes it back and keeps the
play alive and if Victor hman just repeats get it
back to the front of the net this time it's Hegel
in front look at Paul gets a hand on it that's
not easy that's staying with the puck staying in
it staying on it it's Nick Paul makes the play
there and it's Hegel who paid it off this will
be goal number 15 of the Season shots are now 122
in favor of the lighning in this period they got
two goals to show for here comes another radish
there's a drive and a save by vanichic on that one
timer from stanos yeah second period long chain
their dmen in particular are running around and
the lightning are playing in fed offensive
hockey Mercer back to way he splits the D
Mercer's in save by vasovski oneon-one though
and he'll remember it he's got good reach but
he just assumes that Mercer is going to speed to
the outside Mercer's acceleration fools him liberg
is not going fast enough and as soon as he crosses
his feet and misses on the reach Mercer Double R
with a hatrick in this building last season long
shot never got through and Paul can't get it out
held in turned back up there by heer he's got
Ro shoes rebound scores batted in by Andre poot
the former lightning forward with his first goal
and point is used to but there's the turnover and
that's what caused the problem now the lightning
are all out of position it's an out overload down
near their net Nick Paul turned the puck over all
three forwards really are in trouble Victor hman
chases the play outside dishes to COV here's COV
up high in the zone takes the shot and man got
a piece of that out in front for Point TI just
wide back out in front per sh oh what I say rbow
scor and the captain answers right back SOS makes
it 3-1 lightning another good shift right after it
lightning had a couple of turnovers but it's the
top line again perik's moving in from the point
and pass from Guess Who 86 COV puts it right
on the tape kik's really good shot vanich with
a really nice save back down low here's Paul
coo drop headman looks cudra onetime kicks a
rebound oh off the post for points Paul kucherov
in front po Point wait shoots B check came across
took it away he still picking himself up and now
a pass up ahead it's AC in stopped by vanck that
was very close indeed from sliding through the
five hole face off chipped out by Brat he takes
off here's jper brat down the ice in and scores
fast seski got a piece but the heavy wrer from
brat squeaks through and it's a one-goal game
again Victor Hedman tries to stand up like he
did so effectively early on they apparently
must have talked about that because they took
advantage of him brat Banks it off the wall and
gets by him radish does the right thing he took
that pass away vasileski just just a little bit
of a tweak that arm didn't get tight into his
body here's points fans on it and almost was
there for COV now St goes in krov got a shot
away and Vanek again makes a big save's Power
Play is good six overall second on the road but
here come the lightning shorthanded it's m across
the de again stop by Van the best action was the
lightning two onone Tyler M with a beautiful
little play that was really hard to execute
Nick Paul along the wall there trying to make
plays coming out of this blue line the way New
Jersey's going sometimes you just got to bump
it off off the wall get it out of the zone and
get on them in the neutral zone turnovers inside
your own Blue Line here's a big turnover scores
bounc right to point and he did not miss 4 to
Tampa [Applause] Bay waiting on the opposite
side of the ice and it is a bad turnover here
ball tries to make a play into the middle of
the ice and braen point who' been all alone on
the other side just steps into the middle of
the ice that's the problem with those types of
break head been Lo the drop trying to find the
handle and they do not get it out held in there
by nitz nit dish es off gets it back here's the
shot rebound they score at the side of the net
that is Tyler T Foley and they are back within
one with 238 on the clock he just Parks himself
off to the left side of vasileski lightning have
numbers in the middle of the ice but Victor Hedman
is late getting to tley New Jersey Devils have two
guys on the inside both poot and T that was a
dangerous setup for the lightning you can't let
two guys in there and you be on the outside that's
your net it should be the other way around 1 pass
up picked off by coov COV to CI again dishes
off and they score Brandon heel fty Nets goal
53 he could see what Hughes wanted to do ran
his eyes read where the forward was going up
the wall he was already two steps in that
direction Hughes didn't fool him by looking
up the middle there's cooch outstanding easy
little play to Celli Celli to Hegel and two
goalies who [Music] are at Center M gives a
puck up to headman headman takes a look gives
it up the ice for point and his shot scores bred
points with another empty Nets goal his second
and that should do [Applause] it Victor Hedman
under control the first pass coming out that's
the one that matters and greaten point as on
this Saturday night this gas forella weekend
the Lightning win their seventh straight on home
ice and go in the break with another two points